A lot of DGers
noticed
that they're getting their their memberships refunded from the
YouTube channel. Does anybody know why Destiny lost his ally?
Can anybody remind me? I'm forgetting. He's like acting like
they're too scared to stand with me on this. Like they hadn't
just about kind of like distanced themselves before. Dan is in
a ditch tweeting about his son. Dan is in a ditch tweeting about
his he was not happy about Dan. Okay. And some people suspect,
is this uh is this Destiny a little worried about how Dan's campaign
has been kind of weaponized against him
everywhere. There's content all over the place. There's so many
things going on all at the same time. It's crazy.
Let me run through my docket really quickly. Okay, I've got some
early tweets, some some just some, you know, quick hits that
we can do right off the bat. Then we're going to get into Destiny
apparently demonetized on YouTube. Uh mixed feelings on this.
Like mixed feelings as in obviously if it was due to pressure
from the Trump admin or even perceived pressure on YouTube's
part from the Trump admin. That feels really gross to me. But
I haven't seen any of the Hassan channels complaining about it.
Maybe we should go look at some of the Hassan channels. I think
the unfortunate thing is is it's connected. People feel like
it's connected to some other stuff. I think there's a real chance
that Destiny's just been breaking the toos enough on his channel
that he's gone or that he's demonetized, right? Like it's I that's
how it is, man. That's just how it is, dude. So I Yeah, I don't
know on that one. Like I
We'll see. We'll see if anything comes out about it. I also don't
think it'll last, right?
I just don't think it'll last. I think he'll get his back. How
much did his channel bring in? Probably hundreds of thousands
of dollars. But like there are just so many instances of like
death threats and and him standing on the the death threats or
glorifying violence or doxing that like how many times can you
stand on glorifying death threats, doxing uh like glorifying
violence? Sorry, glorifying violence, death threats, doxing,
doxing threats. How long can you stand on all of that and say,
"No, no, no. I totally meant to do that." Uh what platform? It's
on YouTube. Yeah.
Yeah.
So, I don't know how long you can do those things for and still
be safe. So again, we'll have to get into it because there's
there's this we're gonna have to start I think we're all gonna
have to apologize to some of the people that we said had trunked
derangement syndrome back in the day. Okay?
Cuz I I think we're going to start realizing that
actually all of those places, all of those guardrails, all those
places people kind of sawed out about Trump in every one of those
places. It might have been actually appropriate to soy the out.
>> It might have been pretty appropriate to soy the [__]
out in those cases. Five.
>> I don't care about his dying sister. I can't give up
on the race. >> His sister's life comes before my >> Okay.
Thank you for the five speed racer. No, I I'm just saying because
what's happening now, like we'll get into why NextStar took why
Nextar decided they weren't going to air Jimmy Kimmel anymore.
And then we'll get into maybe some Disney stuff, some ABC stuff.
And the these different groups have different ideas of why they're
doing the thing. But like probably
probably all of those norms that have been violated by Trump,
he doesn't even have to directly use the government against people
anymore. People have started doing the thing. They'll started
they've started doing this where they'll just do the thing that
they think Trump will want hoping they'll get favorable outcomes.
And that's the like that's that's the ethical standard needs
to be. You need to be above as the president of the United States.
You need to be above the appearance of impropriety. You can't
just avoid impropriety. You have to be above the appearance of
it. And Trump from moment one has never been above the appearance
of it. He's never cared about the appearance of it. Right. But
now we've got all these like weird backroom quid proquo going
on where it's like, "Oh yeah, well, we're going to fight. We're
going to get rid of Charlie Kirk and we're going to make a statement
and we're going to hope that you just let like our monopolistic
uh our monopolistic merger go through." Like, okay, that seems
broken. That seems totally wrong, right? Yeah. There's just there's
a couple things like this and as we go through it, I'm like starting
to re-evaluate how I think about it. Are you in No, I Dude, no,
no, no, no. Hold on. Let me pull this up. This is one of our
conservative friends. So, are you in your chat going to celebrate
the death of Asmin Gold's dad tonight? Because it's on my bingo
card waiting for He deserved it. No. Asmin Gold's dad was awesome.
Wait, Asmin Gold's dad was like a Trumphating
gigad. Okay, that dude had TDS out the wazoo. We love Asmin Cold's
dad. What are you talking about? We would never get mad at Asmin
Gold's dad. Are you serious? Also, we would be sad even if it
was uh even if he was a Trumper. Okay, even if he was MAGA, we
would be sad. But you just kind of you didn't take that into
account. That guy hated Trump, bro. That guy absolutely hated
Trump. What's up, Lil Wabby? The other thing we're going to have
to get into, which is a little funny, is we're going to have
to talk about the the Hassan stuff, okay? And unfortunately,
all of the liberals who are now like, "Yeah, we hate fascists."
are about to realize why you can't just use the label of a terrorist
organization as your impetus for deplatforming someone who supports
them. Okay? Because that line disappears before you realize where
it is. Okay? This was the argument I made to a bunch of people
and every so many people in my chat in my community absolutely
hated me for it. But it's like, hey, the State Department has
the universal sole power, okay, to name whatever terrorist organizations
they want. And if Trump directs Rubio to name Antifa as a terrorist
organization, then supporting Antifa is going to be the pe the
arguments people are making is speech in favor of of a terrorist
organization is material support. And we should try to get Hassan
thrown in jail. We should talk to the government about this.
It's about to apply to like all of us. That that standard is
about to apply to all of us. Okay? Well, anybody who doesn't
like Trump, you know, on your constitution. So, I it's just funny
to me that almost everybody's going to have to come to my side
on that argument. Uh, that was a great argument. It was awesome
the whole time. Um,
I'm not even going to say it was like only it's not like my argument
really. It's just the sensible argument the whole time. What
stops people from just calling themselves something else? Well,
the whole thing is if you're going to if you're going to say
these people are fascists and we hate them because they're fascists,
right? That's what I'm telling you is they're going to start
taking that as Antifa pro Antifa sentiment. That's what they're
going to do. They're going to do it to all of you guys. It's
just it's just sad.
Yeah.
Hold on. We have a a meme incoming. Hold on. Hold on. Let me
get back to my blast off tweet, guys. There's a blast off tweet
pinned in the kick chat. Engage with the blast off tweet. Like
the blast off tweet. Let me go to my profile. Boom. Boom. Boom.
There we are. Here we are. Okay.
Can I switch over to my browser now? I think so. It's time.
There it is. Wait, there it isn't. What the? No browser here.
Have you seen Yeah, I've got the Ken Clippenstein article ready
to go, too. This is like the actual moment. This is going to
flip a lot of people. Is this part of the Trump administration
and how it's Yeah, I realize the browser's not showing. I I realize
I have to fix it. Give me a second. Um, but it's I think this
is going to fix people. I think we're we're on the way. Okay,
we're on the way to fixing everybody. Now, this is going to be
the overreach people needed. I hope. I pray. I pray, man. Not
the Republicans, not any of those people. It's going to be like
the libs who are like in the middle. Okay. Anybody who's like
in the middle on this, it's got to be convincing them soon. Although,
I've been reading some some Adam friended tweets and have not
been a fan of some of the tweets. Okay. Not been a fan. Okay.
We got this blastoff tweet. I just sent a meme really quickly.
Okay.
It's a This will be a part of the content we're about to do.
All right. Do nothing. Win. How does Assan How does he keep doing
it? How does he keep doing it? He's like Mr. Magcoo. His enemies
just keep destroying themselves.
They just keep doing it. This guy, how every time? Again, I'm
I'm not going to like if this was Destiny actually losing his
monetization, I personally would celebrate cuz I think he's a
terrible human being. I think he's done terrible things and I
think he's broken the TOS. I think there's like no no defense
of like him being a monetized creator online at this point. I
don't think there is. Okay. Or at least not uh like platform
monetized creator. Maybe I I don't know if I take away his ability
to transact. That's that's an even more extreme step. I don't
think we do that, right? I don't think I I think there's evidence
for that. But um but I I think this is cool. I just think it's
going to get reversed. I think this is probably due to some things.
I think from what I recall, August pretty good at, you know,
filing his YouTube appeals and [__] I just I think
it's going to get reversed. So, I do think it would be deserved.
Uh I don't like the impetus for it if it was, you know, some
kind of government overreach that caused it to happen. Dan about
to hit the peace sign and fade away. Dude, I don't know if you
guys saw it. I think uh I think Desi was kind of freaking out
about this stuff last
dude.
Uh
unfortunately,
unfortunately, there are just starting to be good memes coming
out about this. Okay. Shotch
chaser. Shot
chaser. Do I have to say that again? Shot chase.
It's up. It's up. It's up. This is not making fun of Listen,
it just happens. I'm sorry that it's funny. I don't want it to
be funny. It just happens to be very funny. Okay, you got to
you got to let it go sometimes.
Some people were hypothesizing that Destiny heard about this
last night, like the demonetization. Maybe got an email and he
was quite upset about it last night. There's some logs here.
Let's check this out real quick. Check this out.
Okay.
Uh, country on the verge of a fascist takeover and 90% of chat
is filled with spamming about TV shows.
I think supposed to be defe. Is the Discord more active? Yeah,
this is 2027.
Trump is on life support. Here's this is the one. Oh, the year
is 2027. Trump is on life support but still build out for TV
appearances. The US has been in civil war for 16 months. Food
is scarce. Medicine and ammunition hard to come by. Dan is in
a ditch tweeting about his son. Dan is in a ditch tweeting about
his He was not happy about Dan. Okay. And some people suspect,
is this uh is this Destiny a little worried about how Dan's campaign
has been kind of weaponized against him? What do you guys think?
Is there a little bit of that there? Is that I don't know. I
don't know. Listen, I'm not necessarily saying that, but some
people are arguing this. Okay. All right. Let's go down to the
bottom. Unreal. I think I might do this event and retire to gaming
for 6 months or indefinitely, which you're going to cover in
just a little bit. Okay, un America. That that event went on
today. That's why we're kick only today, guys, because to watch
that event, you cannot watch that event and like Destiny's appearance
at it on a platform that has a toos that like a a harshly enforced
toss. Okay, that we're going to have to disavow. There's just
there's a some colorful language that we don't support. Okay,
I think it should just be a fa conservative/fascist government.
people like Hutch, Pisco, CNN, etc. can do their thing. It's
just way too many with zero. It's fine. There's no point. Uh
so, I don't know. You You just don't have to You don't have to
stand behind
uh or refusing to disavow desperate decentralized terrorist violence.
You just don't have to do it. You never have to do it. You You
can literally do all of the things. You could say, "Oh, I have
a hard time disavowing this when I see the president like avowing
this kind of thing." Basically saying it's one-sided when it's
clearly not, right? You could even say it, but you you should
just go in the the one millimeter that you have to go to say
actually, yeah, that shooting at Charlie Kirk was bad. It's so
easy to understand, man. Any comment on Chud's allegation? Uh,
yeah, that's that's like a thing that's been talked about, bro.
I'll I'll refer to my previous statement on it. I believe that's
the Riley Mint video. Yeah, I'll refer to my previous statement.
This is a name ski IP banned. Aristotle, you are literally constantly
fighting on every single front every day as a liberal, and there
isn't a single person with a spine out here that can do any of
it besides me apparently. And it's just too tiring at this point.
He guys, he's out here taking all the arrows, calling for calling
for, you know, basically like a vowing violence. And he's doing
it for you. All right? He's doing it for you. It's just all for
you guys. Don't worry about it. Crime uh crime boss rock a city.
Don't worry about it. Okay? Shnor is there literally aren't so
there literally aren't this is about allies maybe lamount they're
all spineless
I think they're all they would be allies
does anybody know why Destiny lost his ally can anybody remind
me I'm forgetting he's like acting like they're too scared to
stand with me on this like they hadn't disavowed kind of like
distanced themselves before listen Destiny is clearly just exploding
because Discovery is making the case go poorly for him um I don't
know I have I have no idea there only other community we had
a bridge with tortures it because Ethan's a spineless hack as
well. Just a pathetic state of affairs for everyone over here.
Adam Mockler is the only exception to what I said. Dude, Adam
Mockler took my tweet concept. [__] this guy.
What did he say? He's like, I got three executives deplatform
or fired for their comments on on Jimmy Kimmel or something.
He's He steal my concepts, man. All right. So, we had those logs
last night. And then following those logs, we get a Reddit post
that's been removed, but then it it got put back. Just give me
a second. We'll pull it up. We'll pull it up. This is getting
into the demonetization story, guys, just so we're clear.
All right.
Here's a thread.
A lot of DGers noticed
that they're getting their their memberships refunded from the
YouTube channel. Kind of kind of interesting. Not sure. I'm not
So, I'm not sure that this by itself would mean you're demonetized,
right? I don't think so. You could probably shut off channel
memberships and turn it back on. And I think probably when your
memberships auto go off, this email probably comes out. Okay.
But I we'll go a little further into it and I'll I'll give you
what I think happened and then we'll I I'll maybe go over some
other options here. One second. Because you and your ilk have
scoped all of Destiny's friends and made him look bad because
y'all are obsessive. Apparently. Yes. Apparently.
Okay. One second. I just got it. Okay.
So, so
a bunch of people got these emails and people pretty quickly
realized this probably means you've been demonetized. I'm guessing
what happens is this email exists on some trigger so that when
your channel memberships go from on to off if you have memberships
out, it just auto emails, right?
Did Destiny do that or YouTube? So, I'm going to tell you what
I assume happened. So, you would write this feature and you would
say, "Okay, you might depending on how you have it hooked up,
you might go if there are people currently subscribed, send an
email to people." So, I'm going to explain it to you, Maximus.
You don't have to keep oscillating in chat. You send an email
to all the people who had their memberships paused and just say
they've been paused. But if somebody gets demonetized,
probably because it autodefaults off the channel memberships.
I'm guessing the way the trigger set up is that when that goes
off, it sends the email regardless of the method by which the
channel memberships have been paused. Now, there are a couple
other details here that go into this. So, if we look at this
YT large monetization checker channel, I don't know if this really
works. I I actually don't know. Okay, I don't know how accurate
it is, but it seems to get most of the things. Okay, it seems
to get most of the the the things here correct. And goes advertising
status ads are not active. And you look at the latest videos
and they do not have ads on them either. So, it seems like the
the monetization and stuff, it it seems to be off, right? Check
your channel. I can't check my channel. I did check uh the Riyal
channel, right? The Riyle channel. It's on. Ads are active. Right.
So, it seemed to from tests from a couple different people get
the actual like status correct. Right. So, I think uh I think
Alex Gekmo tweeted about this as well. Cooked around on Destiny's
channel and he cooked Neto for a few minutes and couldn't get
any ads on his videos, but ads on other channels afterwards.
A few others say they did the same. The websites that claim to
check monetization status are saying it's gone. Not looking good.
So, it does seem like I don't know if YT Large is 100% real.
So, they tested on some channels. They seem it seems to say correctly
whether or not a channel is monetized or not. Okay.
So, so
that is
that seems to be that. Now, could this be that like could it
be that he disconnected his AdSense account? Could it be like
or shut off monetization altogether? Maybe this is something
they did, right? It seems possible that that's what happened.
Um, I don't know. I don't know if those tests have been done
yet. I'm sure other people will do those tests, right? and the
crazy stuff he was saying. We don't know. We'll probably never
know what it was from, right, if it did happen unless he talks
about it. So,
yeah.
I I the thing I noticed that makes me think that it is not just
I think it's probably something tied to his AdSense because what
actually did happen as well is I'm aware of two other channels
that he is the known owner of, okay, that I believe they all
feed into the same AdSense. There's Last Night on Destiny, which
is also one of his channels, and there's Destiny or Destiny Clips,
which is also one of his channels. Both of these channels also
demonetized. So, that makes me think that probably not just a
video on his channel. It was probably a like a more uniform action.
Makes me lean towards like a nonautomated process. Maybe not
even a report process. Okay. Because this seems like all of these
got shut off. So, so probably one of two options. either you
know somebody if I had to guess and I can't say for sure this
is just based on you know how I think most tech companies code
things how like a little bit of experience and then a little
bit of deduction okay one of two options either somebody at YouTube
was like was like YouTube legal some some form of of YouTube
higherup got this and decided to come in and say okay all of
these channels got to go or there was like a complaint made against
his AdSense account or he shut it off himself somehow across
all of these which would, I guess, maybe make sense. Some people
have been saying, well, if he goes demonetized, maybe he's less
of a problem for reports and stuff. He thinks he's getting mass
reported. It's possible. Uh, I think he said August basically
got a lot Oh, August got
a split of the YouTube money. Yeah. So, August is I don't know
what's going on with August. Apparently, August made comments
on it, though. Let me see. Let me see if there's anything here.
Oh, no. I've not seen any comments from August yet. Nope. Don't
see any comments from him. Uh, let's see. Um, I wouldn't worry
about August. Sure. I'm sure August has made a lot of money.
You know, Israel and Google came to a $45 million deal. Destiny
will be back stronger with new Israeli tech. I Dude, really?
Cuz that's not even how much they offered Charlie Kirk $150 million.
What is What is YouTube getting for 50? Feels like not very much.
Is there a chance it's a time-sensitive delayed moderation action
from one of the previous court cases? Crash out/doces.
It's possible that it is from reports that work their way up
for some of the other content. I know some people I like I it's
possible cuz he has done a lot of toos violating. Okay. And I
don't believe that there's any reason that YouTube wouldn't look
at some offplatform activity. Okay. So I do I do think he's been
like basically breaking the toos basically like totally gambling
with his channel for a long time now. And it's possible that
that stuff has come back to bite him. Now I I tend to think that
it's something outside of the standard process because all three
channels were hit. I don't think you get all three channels hit
at the same time without it being them doing it themselves or
like a YouTube higher up coming along and saying, "Yeah, these
channels are off now." I've seen people speculate that, you know,
this happens to big channels. This has happened to other YouTubers.
I've seen stuff like that. I don't know on that front to tell
you the truth. I actually I'm unsure. I'm uncertain. Pretty sure
Hassan talked to YouTube about the death threat Destiny made.
Yeah, that was another one, right? He did say he did have the
death threat from from Destiny as well. So, like there are a
lot of Desi's been taking a lot of risks with his platforms.
Um, yeah, that's not really much else to say. What is the Fresh
and Fit channel show? I'd have to go find their YouTube ID. Hold
on.
Cuz I know for Steven Crowder, it's off here. Give me a second.
I'm looking for it. Fresh and fit. Fresh fit pod. Okay. I can't
find Fresh and Fit. I can't find Fresh and Fit on on anything.
If anyone's got their address, I throw it into the site or something,
but I can't find I can't find it. Oh, hold on. Fresh and fit
YouTube. I I'm just trying to find their
It's Fresh Fit Miami. I knew that. What the hell? Why isn't this
showing up? Give me a second. Oh, there it is. Okay,
there. Here we'll see now. Fresh and fit. The channel Fresh and
Fit is not monetized.
Look,
look, not monetized. You know, specifically that when you lose
monetization that it doesn't target the AdSense account itself
directly. Um, so there would be different types there. You could
lose your AdSense account, but I don't think the AdSense account
I think the AdSense account goes into how you get paid out. I
don't think it's actually related like I think you can have an
AdSense account where you buy ads, right? Where you buy ads or
you sell ads through Google. You like you put ads on your website.
Different things feed into the AdSense account. That's just like
I think how they did payments from the beginning. So like if
you had, you know, if you were running Google ads on your website,
you would get paid out through AdSense as well. Destiny just
said they're probably going to permab him. Uh I'm sure that's
like self victimizing. Yeah. Anyway, there's uh there's a lot
of more stuff to get to on this front. Or not more stuff, but
there's um there's just like there's the America [__]
We're going to get through a lot of it today. Okay.
It's some very goofy stuff happening. Okay. These are the emails
I got before Sunday got demonetized.
What? Imager over capacity. Am I the only one getting that the
hell or is that just rejecting my YouTube? Okay. Oh, these are
the emails I got when President Sunday got demonetized.
Channel memberships feature on President Sunday has been paused.
So, you're non-recurring. No longer offering memberships. So,
you're non-recurring. Yeah. So, okay,
there you go. So, thank you, Ethan Klein. But, uh,
interesting. So, it seems like those emails do go out when when
Sunday was demonetized as well. Interesting. Very interesting.
So, it looks like Hey, it looks to me like like it's a real demonetization.
again. Uh, who knows how long it will who knows how long it'll
last for.